There's nothing worse than watching a trailer
for an upcoming movie you're excited about—only
to realize halfway through that the trailer
is giving away the entire plot.
And it isn't just a modern problem, either.
Marketing companies have been putting major
spoilers in trailers for years.
Let's take a look at some trailers that totally
ruined the movie.
And, well, spoilers ahead, obviously.
Last House on the Left
The trailer for 2009's Last House on the Left
leaves no surprise unspoiled as it bounces
through the entire script.
In the space of two and a half minutes, we
learn that two young women have an unfortunate
run-in with fugitives, who then execute one
and leave the other one in a lake.
As they look for a place to hide overnight,
the gang ends up at the lake house of the
girl they shot.
If the trailer had stopped there, it would
have been pretty good—unfortunately, it
goes on to show the surviving girl making
it home, and her parents exacting their revenge
on the criminals…including the literal final
scene of the movie.
There's really no point in even watching it
now.
You know everything that happens.
Cast Away
It may be one of Tom Hanks' most celebrated
roles, but anyone who saw the trailer for
Cast Away promptly had the entire plot spoiled
for them.
In the preview, we're shown the plane crash
Hanks' character survives and his arrival
on the island where he's stranded.
Standard trailer stuff.
Really makes you wonder if the guy survives,
huh?
Well...just keep watching the trailer!
It shows Hanks' character building a raft
and writing a note detailing how long he'd
been on the island.
Even worse, it inexplicably tells us that
he survives this harrowing journey and makes
it back home.
The Cast Away trailer is also another one
of those previews that uses the last shot
of the movie as the last shot of the trailer,
so there are literally no surprises left.
Thanks for ruining everything, trailer editors.
"I… have made fire!"
Yup, even that.
Shutter Island
When the first trailer for Shutter Island
was released, Paramount Pictures didn't bother
to hide much of the plot.
In fact, the trailer pretty much neatly summarized
the entire thing.
It becomes evident early on that the disappearance
of Rachel Solando is not the real mystery
here, but the existence of an unknown 67th
patient at the mental institution and the
quickly accelerating deterioration of the
main character's grip on reality.
Thankfully, the trailer left the big, super
twisty twist at the end intact for filmgoers,
but that that point, you could pretty much
forget about enjoying the ride.
The Sum of All Fears
The trailer for Ben Affleck's debut as Jack
Ryan in 2002's The Sum of All Fears is a lesson
in how NOT to do a trailer for a spy film.
This clip sets up the main threat early on:
will Affleck and Morgan Freeman be able to
track down the missing Russian scientists
before they can build a nuclear bomb and use
it in the U.S.?
That sounds like an intriguing plot, and might
have drawn a casual viewer to see the movie.
Unfortunately, the trailer then destroys all
the suspenseful build-up by showing the bomb's
detonation.
The rest of the story, where Ryan keeps the
President from wrongly retaliating against
Russia, seems like a major letdown after such
a big reveal.
Batman v Superman: Dawn of Justice
Naturally, there were several trailers for
2016's mega-movie Batman v Superman: Dawn
of Justice.
But with the second promo trailer, the studio
apparently decided to just give away the entire
plot and hope fans were too devoted to the
brand to care.
The trailer makes no mystery of most of the
critical plot points, with scenes in order
and all the major beats revealed: Lex Luthor
introduces Bruce Wayne and Clark Kent, then
manipulates them both to get them to fight.
The two superheroes duke it out for a while,
which is in the title, so that's fine.. until
surprise!—here's Doomsday to fight them.
But wait—who appears to save the day?
Why it's Wonder Woman, and the duo becomes
a trio—working togethecr to battle the bad
guy and save the world.
Despite all the spoilers, the movie made over
$870 million at the worldwide box office,
so apparently the strategy paid off.
Final Destination
All the films in the Final Destination series
are pretty bad about putting huge spoilers
in their trailers.
While we know the entire premise of the movies
revolves around the demise of people who cheated
fate, spoiling the characters' comeuppance
in the trailers pretty much defeats the purpose.
In the trailer for the first Final Destination
movie alone, we get to see Tod, Ms. Lewton,
and Billy meet their gruesome fates.
Later installments in the franchise are similarly
spoilery, usually revealing the demise of
at least a third of the cast along the way.
Kingsman: The Golden Circle
In 2014's Kingsmanc: The Secret Service, Colin
Firth's character Harry Hart is shot in the
face by Valentine.
It's implied that Hart is out of the picture,
with Eggsy taking over his role within the
Kingsman spy organization.
With the first official trailer for The Golden
Circle, the Fox marketing team decided to
spoil a huge secret in the final seconds of
the trailer:
"Oh my God…
Harry?"
This revelation didn't sit well with director
Matthew Vaughn, who said:
"I begged the studio not to reveal it.
Because it’s the whole driving force of
the first act and if you didn’t know that
scene it would’ve made the whole audience
gasp."
Apparently, the marketing guys didn't take
the hint, because the second trailer for The
Golden Circle showed even Harry in action,
along with a reveal of Julianne Moore's character
as the big bad.
Friday the 13th
Although the 1980 horror film Friday the 13th
eventually went on to become a massive box-office
success and spawned an entire franchise, the
trailer for the movie definitely didn't do
it any favors.
In typical '80s style, the trailer for Friday
the 13th has a voiceover—but this time,
the marketing team at Paramount didn't bother
trying to entice audiences with a mysterious
backstory or synopsis.
Instead, they just showed every character's
demise while the voiceover counts them.
"One."
Not only does the trailer have no qualms about
spoiling every twist in the movie, it also
takes a weird turn—in counting up to the
13 in the title, the trailer implies that
there will be 12 casualties during the film,
but there were actually only ten: the nine
victims and Pamela Voorhees herself.
So much for truth in advertising.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!